oui
[Musique]
or je suis quoi mais je suis content et
toi tu crois mais je suis content aussi
alors qu'est ce que raconte le
marseillais que je suis content
c'est parti pour des vacances
j'ai gagné ça va te faire tout drôle
depuis le voir tous les jours derrière
son pupitre je n'ai quand même pas le
faire redoubler pour mon plaisir à toi
marcel
et
les
ah ça
[Musique]
oh misère une vraie des choses
être bien qu'il aurait le béguin toute
ma nous la présenter il veut pas parce
que c'est une forêt hante c'est la
vérité la vérité tu sais même pas de
quoi tu parles
un bon sourit
au nom des années tu l'as eu au milieu
de tas classement
il vend des paroles
[Musique]
oui
la couture le foie gras
regarde les filles à voir ses secrets
comme nous tous
[Musique]